okay you guys should be able to hear me
well if those of you guys who were
wondering with the two hours of sleep
Edition means it means that I'm running
out two hours of sleep I've been up
since like 1:00 o'clock yesterday
afternoon like I am exhausted I had a
long night the other night and I had a
long night last night last night I was
going through and I was looking through
all the Deadpool core stuff and trying
to figure out like what I should do and
and what characters are worth doing
because not the problem with the
Deadpool Corps is a lot of the Deadpool
core characters like 99% of them we
actually see in Deadpool kills Deadpool
there's like a handful of them that we
see before then and so those guys who
were asking about like like panda pool
panda pool is gonna be a little bit
difficult to do because we won't see
panda pool until Deadpool kills Deadpool
so we can't really do a lead-up but in
any event you know I think I think it'll
be a fun a fun series of videos cuz
anything Deadpool related seems to be
you guys really really seem to love it
so with that being said let's see let's
let's scroll through here how's
everybody doing today
how're you guys doing this one well you
guys not in church okay um let's scroll
up okay questions haven't started coming
in yet um oh yeah somebody asked about
the hitbox okay so for those of you guys
who are following the weekly pull
podcast we had an announcement at the
end of the podcast last when we did that
the weekly poll is moving to hitbox if
you guys are ever curious about updates
for the weekly pull different things
like that
you can always check the weekly poll net
and go to the forums and that will
basically give you a Tiffany and Daniel
are really good at making announcements
for the website as well as what we plan
on doing with pod
but you can always follow myself Benny
and Sal on Twitter add Sal says what and
comics Torian and commerce explained and
and will always keep you guys posted on
what's going on with with the website
and what's going on with the podcast and
and so on and so forth so I'm glad you
guys are doing well
we will do a spawn explained at some
point in time I can't tell you exactly
when just because right now like quite
literally convergence and secret wars
are right around the corner so in truth
we probably won't have a whole lot of
time to do spawn them we just don't
really have a lot of time to focus on
him another thing I want to ask you guys
while you guys are fresh into this
podcast and on my Twitter is fresh in
this live stream I made weight towards
into assets which I think I will because
a lot of people are probably be rolling
in by then but um this was gonna be
relatively short we're gonna keep this
one in about half an hour 45 minutes
because again i yeah i am very very
tired so I am very exhausted right now
but you know I love doing comics and
coffee because I love talking to you
guys I think that that interacting I
think you tubers interacting with their
fanbase is one of the most important
things and I think a lot of youtubers
don't do that I think a lot of youtubers
are just like here's content and then
you just never really like talk to them
on a personal level so but those of you
guys who are new to comics and coffee
comics the coffee is just a general name
because this is a comic book channel but
this is a Q&A so you guys can ask me
pretty much anything and if I'm
comfortable answering it that I will if
not then I'll just be like I'm not gonna
answer that or I'll just ignore your
question it's a terrible thing to do I
know but you know what else what else
can we do what do I think the aftermath
of secret Wars will be and Tom Brevoort
pretty much told us during the Marvel
announcement what the world is going to
be like what he's basically saying now
is is this really the Church of Rob it's
really kind of difficult to wrap around
like even now I'm trying to wrap my head
around it because it's so different from
what we've been experiencing but right
now there's this great big huge Marvel
multiverse and there's no real like
format to it it's just universes are out
there
and sometimes we see them sometimes we
don't there's no real design for why
they do what they do what Marvel is
doing is they're consolidating all of it
and they're saying this battle world is
going to hold all the multiverses so
think of it as though this battle world
is a giant jar and inside of this jar
are a series of golf balls each of these
golf balls representing its own universe
so X by 92 is going to be its own
universe spider-verse will be its own
universe will see will probably see
multiple versions of Jay jonah jameson
each and within each of these individual
universes we'll see a version of Jay
jonah Jameson maybe in X been 92 if we
see them crossing over with that version
of spider-man we may see Jay jonah
Jameson in I don't know Age of
Apocalypse if we see you know if they
decide to go that route do they actually
you decided to introduce his character
in it's just one of those weird things
that's the direction things are going in
so what we're gonna be having during
Secret Wars I guess once all that comes
to an end that's what the universe is
going to be that's what the multiverse
is going to be so so what you see is
what you get when it comes to Secret
Wars I do need some coffee how much did
you like Howard the victim of one I
actually have on read Howard the Duck
number one I'm not the biggest fan of
Howard the Duck I thought he was kind of
a goofy character but I may check him
out I mean I check out how the duck
number one and see what I think can I
stand up and dance now
any chance of explaining ving Riley
unless Ben Riley comes back as part of
spider-verse which he's not I mean they
killed him off I mean I don't really see
a reason to amuse characters dead now so
there's really I don't really see a
reason to explain Ben Riley um I don't
know we may do that at some point in
time but let's see the had a Deadpool
get in the multiverse because last time
he was in real life watching the writers
of the book after he killed Swamp Thing
okay um that one's actually kind of an
interesting question if you recall I
think because that this is level up row
that asked this question I have a
feeling that where you stopped was
Deadpool kills the Marvel Universe they
have was called a Deadpool Killa G
a three-part series is Deadpool kills a
Marvel Universe Deadpool Killa straight
in and then Deadpool kills Deadpool we
already did Deadpool kill a straight in
so if you're wondering how it is that
this alternate universe version of
Deadpool ends up and I guess in this
multiverse then go back and watch the
Deadpool Killa straited and that'll
explain everything
so but I guess to answer your question
in a really short roundabout way what
happened was at some point along the
line after he presumably killed the
writers then he ended up jumping into
the multiverse from there like he had a
multi multi dimensional transporter and
he ended up in the reality of of oh god
what were their names the mad thinker
and these different guys use their
multi-dimensional teleporter and began
hopping rather dimension killing off the
archetypes for superheroes that was the
basis for Deadpool kill asserted in my
opinion it wasn't the best Deadpool
story but nonetheless you know it's it's
part of the trilogy so let's see do you
have any idea what's going on with
Captain Marvel and the Carroll core is
it a multi Russell group of Carol
Danvers that were actually not sure
about um I have a feeling that the Carol
core is gonna be like the Nova Corps
it's gonna be Captain Marvel and it's
gonna be all these different versions of
Captain Marvel different alternate
reality versions of Captain Marvel it
may not just be Carol Danvers anybody
that took up the role of being Captain
Marvel in an alternate reality may very
well be housed in there um Tom Brevoort
didn't really give us a whole lot of
information it wasn't like it was with
Thor core where he said that Thor core
is going to be every single version of
Thor that we've ever seen this ever
existed in Marvel Comics he didn't
really give us any details about about
the Captain Marvel core but I assume
it'll be like that I don't really see a
reason why I wouldn't but either way
like I'm definitely gonna check it out I
mean I hope you guys are too because I
think that that uh the Captain Marvel
core will be pretty cool what for Marvel
characters would you like to see in a
Netflix series after the four defenders
finish oh god I mean the cool thing
about Netflix about having a show on
Netflix is you can do pretty much
anything you want to like you can get
away with a lot of stuff you can have
adult oriented content if you wanted to
by simply signing the fact that it's not
or television and so those rules don't
apply I would want to see some dark and
gritty characters like Deadpool
definitely I don't want to see a
Deadpool on Netflix series they can have
all the humor
they can have all the humor but it also
needs to have like the really dark
element of Deadpool I came just having
that really dark humor and just
murdering people in the blood and the
gore and all that kind of stuff that's a
staple of Deadpool comics it definitely
that definitely needs to happen um I'd
like to see a darker and grittier x-men
series like one where the I guess the
x-men are where they cuss and where they
they carry on and where you see a lot of
violence and everything's like that I'd
like to see that as a series I think
you'd actually be pretty cool um aside
from that maybe the Punisher I think the
Punisher would be a great series for
Netflix just because of the nature of
the Punisher of Frank Castle and I don't
know you guys answer that one who would
be your fourth pick mmm moon nights a
good one moon night would be a great
series to have on Netflix oh my god that
would be awesome
Oh see do I know what Deadpool I'm doing
next well I asked the question at the
end of the video which Deadpool people
wanted me to do if they wanted like I
basically left it to you guys to decide
and at the moment right now I think it's
actually a pretty close close call
between head pool zombie Deadpool and
Lady Deadpool so we may just end up
doing Lady Deadpool and and then get
into head pool necks just because I
don't know maybe we'll do head pool
first because head pool leads into Lady
Deadpool like the Deadpool Merc with a
mouth that leads into that story so I
don't know either way like we'll figure
it out let's see rob is a genius I'd
never thought of a Netflix Deadpool
series I'm sure a lot of people have
thought of a Deadpool Netflix series
let's see Darkhold Redeemers thoughts on
the latest episode of the flash
um oh oh man okay I assume and spoiler
alert for everybody who hasn't seen the
flash yet I assume that your
with the most recent episode the one
where we learned that that
what's-his-name is actually a abhorred
thawne of Thrawn i guess is his last and
i don't know how to pronounce his last
name but he's professor zoom basically
the reverse-flash where he came out and
admitted that and where Barry Allen
ended up jumping into the past by like
an hour I think or something like that
that's huge because I think DC setting
up for the flashpoint event so here's
what I think DC was doing I think they
were experimenting they were at least I
hope that's what they were doing they
were taking arrow they were taking the
flash they were saying let's do these
shows and and see what's to see what's
going on and no I'm not gay and let's
see what's going on and I think that
with the resounding success of the flash
and arrow I think what this has done is
it's given them a trump card if at some
point along the line the writing for the
show is begin to take off the writing
for the show is begin to sort of
dissipate or they begin to go south
people begin to lose interest in the
flash to begin to lose interest in arrow
and they lose interest in you know all
these different all these different
things then that means that they could
basically launch flashpoint and the
flash TV show and they could come back
and they could say okay Gotham and
Supergirl and arrow and flash all these
shows are reset and now they share a
single continuity which i think would be
an awesome idea but again that's really
just kind of speculation on my part
anyway so spoilers are done spoilers are
over but uh but yeah let's see do I
think Eddie will become a reverse flash
I don't think so um it's possible but I
don't I don't think so
I think he's to be too solid of a
character to take that route your voice
doesn't really match your appearance I
thought you would look different darker
and thinner not trying to offend that's
one of the funny things is very rarely
do voices ever matched the physical
appearance er for some reason we always
like build up what we think people look
like in our heads and then we see them
and we're like well that's
kinda weird but that's not what I
expected like okay here's a perfect
example so so New York Comic Con it was
when me Bennion salmet for the first
time and and Dave yeah we all met for
the first time and and all I ever seen
from Benny was what he was on skype and
Salo was the same way there was like
there was no perspective there was
nothing to to give to compare like you
know what they looked like too in terms
of like their physical stature so I meet
many in the airport at ya where do we
meet up at the hell number what Airport
it was I think was in it was in New York
anyway so we meet up at an airport and
and Vinny's like this this big guy like
he's broad shorter he's like a big
hulking guy and I was like oh my god
yes a big dude and then we meet Sal and
sounds like 10 feet tall
Sal is so tall it's ridiculous like it
was funny but it's just one of those
weird things you know where where you
just I guess you just build something up
in your head and then things change we
went to New York Comic Con last year
2014 let's see what do I think of the
upcoming Deadpool movie and trailer um
oh you took the upcoming trailer okay
now are you talking about that the
trailer that was released it like
launched that makes it like force a
movie to be made or are you talking
about the upcoming trailer that hasn't
been released yet because I mean I
haven't seen I don't know but if Ryan
Reynolds is playing Deadpool I'll
probably be satisfied with it I can't
think of anybody else besides Ryan
Reynolds who should play the role of
Deadpool so hmm let's see
what if Luke Cage had a high-pitched
voice what's going on guys this is Luke
Cage I think it'd be hilarious but let's
see what is your opinion of renew your
vows not being Canon because because of
my opinion it makes me angry
well renew your vows will be canon I
mean that's that's the spider-man store
going forward during Secret Wars like
they're they're they're retconning
all that stuff from one more day as far
as I understand that's what Marvel is
doing so so renew your vows will be
canon
as far as I know and I don't think mom
was released anything saying that it
won't be but if they have I haven't read
it so if you know of something then then
send it to me on Twitter so so that I
know Rob what do you think of the 90s DC
versus marvel and do you think anything
like it will ever have it again um let's
see
I think that'll happen again I think
they'll do something like that again
because it was a big success I mean it
was a four-part series it was really
cool and made the amalgam universe so
you had like me and like amalgamations
of DC and Marvel characters I'd be
curious to see if like convergence and
Secret Wars have anything to do with
that if at some point down the line
during a convergence of Secret Wars
Marvel says hey here's the amalgam
universe and convert us a secret Wars I
think it'd be kind of cool um I don't
think we'll get it you know because I
mean we haven't seen that for for quite
some time but nonetheless you know I
think it would be I think it'd be pretty
entertaining
let's see but uh but yeah um I'd like to
I'd love to see something like that come
back I mean for those of you guys who
who aren't sure what we're talking about
with the whole model versus DC thing
there was in the 1990s a four part
limited series called Marvel vs. DC but
some of the other story some of the
older stories before that had crossovers
between Marvel and DC where you had like
I guess Batman vs The Incredible Hulk
and you had Superman and spider-man
which I think was the first Marvel and
DC crossover you had Superman becoming a
Herald of Galactus you have some really
really cool crossover concept somewhere
terrible some are just absolutely dumb
but nonetheless it was a really great
way for fans of Marvel and DC to sort of
bridge this gap and see some of their
favorite characters meeting other
characters and I think that was really
one of the cool things I'd love to see
it make it return I think it'd be
awesome Rob what are your thoughts
if heroes villains do fusion and I don't
mean the crappy fusion but the perfect
con where all the parts of the fusing
individuals are put in perfect place are
we talking about like Dragon Ball Z
fusion because if you took might like
Dragon Ball Z fusion I want to see like
like Batman and
like Batman and Deadpool fuse together
like how awesome would that be like it'd
be Batman with all those gadgets and
like Deadpool's dark sadistic humor I
think it'd be freaking amazing
let's see can you talk about bishop or
cable for some reason those characters
are always confusing are confusing
always going through time okay I get
this question a lot even now like on the
cable video a lot of people say they're
really confused about cable they're not
really sure what to do with cable there
and and even then like the cable video
that I did from back in the day was a
very early video like that was eight
minutes long and it was one of my
earliest videos I may go back with a lot
of those early videos and like revisit
them especially with ex mid-90s who's
coming out it'd be the perfect time to
go back and revision a lot of those
things yet Superman's made a Herald of
Galactus it's really really cool um I I
don't know the name of it but he meets a
fantastic forward cyborg and is in that
universe okay so for those who guys who
were curious when it comes to Bishop
Bishop is a really interesting character
Bishop comes from a timeline that's very
similar to the Days of Future past but
it's not exact there's some big
differences here bishops Tom Bishop is
God he's he's crazy I'm really really
tired so I'm gonna try to make this make
sense as much as I can um Bishop was
initially given to us in Marvel Comics
but he's one of these characters where
his story comes full circle later on in
the comics all we knew about bishops
past was that at some point along the
line some mutant killed a million humans
and so as a result the humans
jump-started the signal program and
we're off to the races that's how that
entire storyline takes place we end up
with this very similar Days of Future
Passed storyline the difference here is
that there comes a point in bishops
timeline where you have the Summers
rebellion and the summers rebellion is
where humans and mutants rise up
together and overthrow the Sentinels and
so what you have left is this very
tedious
Alliance between humans and mutants as
they do what they can to basically
survive and so you have the Xavier
security xavier security enforcers i
think it is XS a e or something like
that but nonetheless and prior to this
you had a bishop who was born into a
camp or i guess he was in one of these
internment camps and that's where the m
comes from on his face it's a brand to
indicate that he is that he's a mutant
all right what happens is Bishop ends up
traveling into the past and as a result
he ends up picking up with the x-men now
we didn't know who this movement was for
like 20 years like we had no idea in
Marvel Comics this is the 1990s or
something like that it's pretty pretty I
think it's mid 90s and Bishop shows up
it wasn't until the Messiah Complex
that Marvel came out and said Hope
Summers is the one that killed a million
humans in bishops timeline or at least
that seems to be the case and so bishops
entire goal is to capture hope summer
zine and basically I think kill her
before she can kill a million humans and
give birth to his timeline but
nonetheless bishops are very easy he's
one of these characters just bashes
through time but that's that's the gist
of Bishop for the most part in Marvel
Comics Cable is far more ridiculous to
sum up Cable in a very simple way cable
is the son of Jean Grey and mmm kinda
Kimber fizz I think it's Madeleine
pretty sure it's Madeleine Pryor my
memory is so hazy right now but anyway
I'm not Jean Grey Scott Summers and
Madeleine Pryor all right what happens
is almost immediately after a cable is
born he comes to the attention of
apocalypse and apocalypse I can't review
once to take cable and make him his heir
but whatever the reason is apocalypse
has his henchmen kidnapped cable and so
the x-men
I guess alongside x-factor travel to
fight apocalypse and they get cable back
in the process cables infected with the
techno-organic virus now because cables
infected with the technical organic
virus we
find that cable is taken into the future
by Rachel summers now this this is why
they see that you see guys this is why
I'm almost rebooting their continuity
Rachel summers the one that takes him
into the future is the same Rachel
summers from the Days of Future past
she was time displaced and that we're
not even gonna go into that just just
believe me when I say that Rachel
summers takes him from the present into
the pattern into the future she takes
him to like the year 4000 or something
like that at the same time the minds of
Jean Grey and Scott Summers are put in
the bodies of two people four thousand
years in the future whenever it is so
they can raise cable as cables raised in
this society apocalypse rules the world
and so because apocalypse rules the
world cables brought up to be an
adversary of apocalypse to do what he
can to free the society from apocalypses
regime and so as a result cable takes
technology from the future and he begins
jumping into the past he travels to a
point in the distant past
right when apocalypse begins I guess
rising to power and he fights apocalypse
and infects apocalypse for the
techno-organic virus because he infects
apocalypse for the techno-organic virus
apocalypse is able to merge or I guess
communicate with celestial technology
and then from there he infects cable
with a techno-organic virus when cables
a child its itself it's a big circle
it's a self repeating prophecy and this
is why Marvel is so convoluted Marvel
needs a new 52 that's what all of us are
hoping Secret Wars is going to be Marvel
coming out of saying okay guys your zero
this is all yours 0 continuity start
over that's what we're all really hoping
for whether we'll get it or not has yet
to be seen but in any event so let's go
to let's get to more questions
that's the bishoping cable I hope that
made sense I hope that's open makes
sense to you here's the Future past I
have no idea I'm but I'm really excited
I'm really really excited like I can't
wait to read years of Future past what's
going on channel Squad everybody who's
just showing up
let's see and Rob's head explodes trying
to explain cable yeah like anybody who
tries to explain cable like their heads
are gonna absolutely blow up it's gonna
be ridiculous
yeah cable is a paradox that's exactly
it like no one summer's how's it exactly
right
what type of remotes do you smoke cable
vision I don't know I mean this is a I
I pee the version too I mean I don't
know what you mean can I explain where
boom a law um our Doctor Doom video
covered everything we know about ro boom
a law basically that he's Doctor Doom
and he's trying to save the multiverse
like that's all we know I mean that's
pretty much it yeah I don't I don't know
see so basically he's his own grandpa I
mean not really but no not really
grandpa that'd be messed up that would
be some screwed up Marvel stuff if like
God if he got you know what we're never
gonna go there this is it's Sunday this
is a church day we're not gonna we're
not gonna go there so heroes reborn um I
doubt we'll do heroes reborn I don't
really see a reason to do heroes you're
born at this point I mean it's not
necessary I mean I guess it the indus
forever the end of the Fantastic Four I
guess it's kind of necessary and like
Franklin Richards dream to mention
whatever it is but all right for those
of you guys who are on the fence those
of you guys who don't know whether or
not you should pick up the Indus forever
and and and pick up like the ending of
the Fantastic Four don't it's absolute
garbage
I hated it it's a terrible series of
stories so it really wasn't worth it
do I think DC versus Marvel Universe
will be battleworld Civil War no I don't
think so
Civil War as far as I understand it it's
gonna be like I guess it's own contained
universe so we're gonna see what it
seems to be what happens if Civil War
never ended or something like that we're
not really sure here but I want to see
hook joining the Red Lantern Corps how
awesome would that be like the Hulk with
a Lantern ring that would be amazing
let's see what do I think of TV little
houses name changed at County pop I
think it's awesome I think that I think
Sal's made a really good decision here
because I think that it is it pops you
know and I think that I don't know I
mean in the end of South channel he can
do whatever he wants to but I think it's
a great idea I think that that with Sal
growing in the direction that he is
growing as fast as he is now I think he
was really kind of hankering for
something like that and so I'm glad to
see it plays out when will I do Planet
Hulk uh I'm not sure at some point I
mean some of these stories in truth seem
to be retellings it's it's one of those
weird things what we may have to do is I
think just have to replant hope when it
comes out and then just look at that and
see what's up and then go from there not
really sure yet it's really difficult to
tell this early with Secret Wars because
we don't know if a lot of these stories
are going to be retellings we don't know
if a lot of these stories are gonna be
continuing universes we don't know if
some of these stories are just what if
stories that are becoming universes
we're not really sure here but at this
point you know it's really just kind of
more of a coin toss so as soon as I get
it figured out I'll definitely you guys
know and give you guys an update so what
is your opinion of dread - not happening
because it makes me so sad oh I know
like dread was amazing that was such a
great film and I'm really disappointed
they're not doing a sequel to it I
thought that was one of the truest
depictions of Judge Dredd from the
comics it was dark it was gritty it
showed just how bad things were in that
society I really want to see a Dredd -
but even if they don't I mean I could
still stand by and say the Dredd was was
an amazing film let's see do you think
spider-man will make a cameo at the end
of Avengers age of Ultron or what do you
think the end credits scene will be I
think the input it seemed had something
to do with the age of Ultron I think it
was I'm sorry with a Civil War I think
it may have been like a government
passing a bill or something like that
but as soon as Marvel got the ability to
put spider-man and
in the in Captain America 3 Civil War oh
I can guarantee you I can guarantee you
like the Sun will rise the post-credits
scene for Avengers age of Ultron is
gonna have something to do with
spider-man mm-hmm if for no other reason
then all its gonna show is a kid being
bit by a spider I mean that maybe that's
it I have no idea what they're gonna do
but it's gonna have spider-man I can I
can envision a situation why wouldn't
because the next biggest movie that
Marvel has coming out after Avengers 2
age of Ultron is Captain America Civil
War that's the next movie everybody's
looking forward to so can I do a special
video that sinestro I've been meaning to
do Sinestro the problem is Sinestro full
origin story is so difficult to find
because it's scattered to the winds so
it's it's a real hassle worst comic book
story arc in comic book history Oh God
probably kill Raven kill Kraven whatever
it is that's a terrible series of
stories um did you hear about Rey
Mysterio possibly I saw that a friend of
mine sent me a message on Facebook and
he was like hey man like like Rey
Mysterio like drop-kicked the guy to
death and I was like no he didn't and
like he showed me the video like he sent
me a link to the video and I was like oh
my god like that's unbelievable and I
think that really is a testament to just
how dangerous wrestling can be see I
think a lot of people don't don't
realize that alive people say oh God
wrestling's fake
and to a degree it is I mean obviously
there's a lot of staging there's a lot
of scripting I mean none of the
situation's are real I mean one of the
really cool thing to listen to for those
of you guys who are curious listen to
Stone Cold Steve Austin's podcast
because that gives you like a lot of
backstory a lot of like a lot of an idea
of what goes on between the shows you
see you learn that like these rivalries
aren't rivalries that they're people who
have been friends for years and years
and years and years and years you know
and and it's one of these really cool
things but nonetheless they're taught
how to take falls or taught how to fall
correctly how to land on their neck how
to do it in a way to where it it keeps
them safe but the problem here is that
box man 2 just got banned
yeah one thing you guys one thing I
wanted want you guys make sure though is
that is that I have no problem like
dropping the banhammer around people who
are gonna try to like spam or troll my
chat because I have no mercy for those
guys anyway so I mean they're taught how
to take Falls they're taught all that
kind of stuff but accidents happen and
and sometimes you know all it takes is a
kick the wrong way and that's it and
that's what happened to him that's it
happened to this guy you know Ray
Mysterio was performing a routine
maneuver something that he's done
countless times I've been following away
Mysterio since he showed up at WCW I
mean he's he's been wrestling for for
about 20 years now for a long time he's
done this move thousands hundreds of
thousands of times and this one time it
just happened to land this guy the wrong
way and it killed him and that's that's
a real disappointment because you know
it's always sad to see somebody dying in
the midst of something they love to do I
guess there's kind of this bittersweet
thing to it but you know the loss of
life in a tragic way is always a
disappointing thing so the best Marvel
story arc civil war hands-down civil war
is the best Marvel story arc of all time
just because again like I love the whole
thing about the the debate and the the
argument of of who's right you know who
comes out on top that that's that's you
know the whole politics of it I think
that's I think that's pretty solid
please mercy Rahab shows no mercy some
guy was just like typing letters in the
chat and and I was like you know what
I'll just ban that guy the heck with it
let's see any redemption for Ghost Rider
moving no Nicolas Cage destroyed the
Ghost Rider franchise like if Marvel's
smart they'll never touch they'll never
ever touch Ghost Rider they'll say you
know what like what it's gonna like this
new in a fall and we're gonna pretend it
doesn't exist that would be my that's
what I would do which I hope that's what
they do
so what material is the Infinity
Gauntlet made out of just wondering
because he slapped caps shield into
pieces or was he able to do that because
of the stones he was able to do that
because of the stones it was it wasn't
because of the material it was it wasn't
like a super-strong like polyester or
something like that it's because he had
like a bat
Samana power but then again it also
could just be because of stano's like I
don't think I've ever seen fan OHS slap
Captain America's shield to pieces like
he did in Infinity Gauntlet when he
didn't have the Infinity Gauntlet that's
because that circumstance never arose
before um Infinity works good but
infinity war is good if you want the
follow-up to Infinity Gauntlet if you
want to find out what happens with the
Infinity watch infinity war has nothing
to do with the upcoming film in the
Marvel Universe so there's that's the
reason why I stopped there was no point
in doing it because when I uploaded the
first video like people watched it they
watched the first like a minute and a
half and as soon as I said this is a
follow-up to Infinity Gauntlet has
nothing to do with the infinity warmth
film like people sort of dropping off
like flies so let's see um hold on I got
a scroll back how would you feel if in
Thor Ragnarok when everything is
destroyed and reborn
it shows the inscription of the hammer
changing heat is she I think that'd be
awesome I think that'd be a great thing
especially if Chris Hemsworth decides he
doesn't want to do Thor anymore if he
says the Thor Ragnarok is gonna be his
last film and they're killing off the
Thor Odinson
and they said we just refer to him as
Odin son they could have somebody else
step into the role now I think having
James Foster knew it would be too cliche
and Natalie Portman would not make a
good action star in a film she's she's
really good at drama she's good at like
every other facet of acting she's just
not really good at action because I
don't think she's really been put in
that role before she's always played the
kind of drama character I guess you know
where like a character in a romance
romance capacity but nonetheless you
know I think with with the right
circumstance maybe she'd be good but I
think like Lady SIF for example would be
a great person to take over the role of
Thor or they may just introduce somebody
new entirely but I think that they're
bringing in a new a new version bringing
in a new version of Thor would be a
great idea so if I could pick an actor
if I could pitch an actor for Adam
warlock who would it be Sean Bean
well no not Sean Bean Sean gonna be a
terrible Adam warlock
um now Sean Bean would be a good Adam
warlock because of the role that Adam
warlock plays so he doesn't really do a
whole lot of fighting Adam warlock
doesn't really do a whole lot of
fighting every once in a while he does
but usually he's like this philosophical
christ-like figure so um let's see what
would be the best comic character to
have as your president ooh
Captain America probably I think you'd
do the most justice what is your opinion
on invincible and will you do an
explained video on the series actually
even read invincible so I don't know um
how would you feel a second how would
you feel that the real shield revealed
in the last episode of agents of shield
is led by the original white Nick Fury
that wouldn't that be something wouldn't
that be something
if oh my god they said this is the real
shield like the other shield is a fake
shield that's just a cover like they're
all life model decoys if he was like
this is the real shield and it's just
like the white Nick theory with an
eyepatch that would be nuts I don't
think they'll do that because one it
would confuse people and two people
would say why is the Samuel Jackson
playing Nick Fury any more lies mean
replaced with a white guy and you would
run into all kinds of politics things
like that um I think that what's been
happening here is is in Marvel Comics oh
here's here's here's here's the comic
version of what's going on in agents of
shield right now there was a point where
Hydra had taken over shield and it was
disbanded but the more relevant factor I
guess the the more comic book II version
of what's going on in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe right now with that
is I was like I hate that I hate that
you have a sneeze like like I just got
trolled by sneeze like it's sitting in
your nose and it's like ah no no I never
it's like oh my god but anyway so what
happened in the comics is Nick Fury had
previously when he was when he was the
head of shield the director of shield he
never actually was in charge of shield
he got his orders from 12 anonymous
people the problem was as time
progressed life model decoys became
sentient they gained intelligence and so
they took over these 12 people and then
when Nick Fury figured out what was
going on they branded Nick Fury a
traitor and they exiled Nick Fury from
shield and then since shield after Nick
Fury 2 gets to kill Nick Fury the result
was that once Nick Fury had defeated
this entire thing once he had end of
this conflict he had taken over shield
entirely and he was the absolute I guess
it knows troll he was the absolute
director shield he had absolute
authority over shield I think that's
what's happening here
I think Nick Fury went underground he
said okay he basically started to the
band sneeze I'm gonna ban the man sneeze
in here in a minute I'm and the heck out
of it I think he reforms shield while he
was underground I think that's what's
gonna be revealed to us and in age of
Ultron because it's really coincidental
they say this is the real shield and
then eight of Ultron is coming out right
now so I think that's really what
happened is Nick Fury form shield and as
we've been keeping it a secret this
entire time but I don't know after
convergence will the DC titles start
from the beginning not to my knowledge
as far as I know the new 52 continuity
that came with conversions or that
started before conversions is staying so
as far as I mean like like that main
eternal for example it would be I guess
coming back or continuing on or so or
you know what have you after convergence
but no they don't think they're starting
all over again after convergence they
may but I don't I don't believe they are
let's see can you do a behind the scene
video on how you make your videos um I
do that once upon a time nobody was
really that interested in it so I just I
didn't worry about
what do I think flat versus Quicksilver
all the flash in Quicksilver super fast
he can run it like Mach 10 which i think
is like 1,100 miles an hour or something
like that
flash can break this like he can run
faster than the speed of light like he
can travel through time so yeah
definitely the flash Darth Vader vs
Batman video that would be amazing I
would love to see that let's see who
would you pick as the new Spider Man oh
man I don't know um honestly if he
wasn't doing the Fantastic Four
I'd say Michael B Jordan would be a
great Miles Morales he's a little older
but I think he'd still be pretty
effective in that role let's see I do
with Thanos cosplay now I'm not doing a
fan oohs cosplay that's that's not gonna
happen
Matthew McConaughey is that a more like
no way what is your opinion of the
Ultimate Universe ending this year
because of my opinion I think the
Ultimate Universe is going to get
screwed over it probably will but the
Ultimate Universe needed to come to an
end at this point I just don't really
care about the ultimate universe Miles
Morales is really the only character
that I care about from the ultimate
universe everybody else is just kind of
like Matt doesn't really interest me too
much
let's see hi when will mr. Sunday join
you in the weekly pool I think you
invited him via tweet yes um we're gonna
try to have him on the first week in
April that's what we're planning for so
yeah that'll be awesome having mr.
Sunday movies on like I'm really looking
forward to it so I have heard a rumor
that Quicksilver is also in human true
or false yes it's true and it's stupid I
can't remember which of which issue of
the X minute I think it was the x-men
but Scarlet Witch uses her powers and
she basically like I think she destroys
everybody or she knocks everybody down
or something like that except for her
family or something like that like and
what it is and magneto is affected by it
it's that's Marvel telling us that
Magneto's not their father and that
they're Inhumans and I'm like oh my god
you know what whatever so it was a
bonehead a decision it was a way to
basically take them away from being
mutants and just throw them in the
inhuman pond that way they can just kind
of roll it all in to the Marvel
Cinematic Universe not the best decision
I mean Marvel was like no no no the
movies don't influence a conflict or the
comics and the comics don't influence
the movies but it's quite clear that
they do let's see you have an
encyclopedic knowledge of the DC and
Marvel comic book universes is the this
is done simply through a reading
research or do you also have an
assistant that helps out no it's just me
I'm the only person that has my videos
like nobody else works in my videos
except for me and it'll it'll stay that
way for the foreseeable future I don't
want anybody else working on my videos
because for me I think that I like
things done a very particular way but
more so than that I think it makes it
more personal if it's just me working on
my videos but nonetheless you know I
mean it's it's it's whatever I mean it's
in the enemy it's it's whatever makes
you happy when is the next weekly next
wired pool a weird pool the end of the
month I think I don't number off top my
head let's see Rob who do you think
would be the villain in the Captain
Marvel movie see that's the problem and
carol danvers doesn't have like a
arch-nemesis per se at least not that I
know of that's one of the reasons why
Carol Danvers was always such a
character that people just never really
got behind because it was never like oh
my god that one foes back let's see if
she can beat them like he was he was
never really like that she was fighting
like this broad sense of feminism in
comic books I guess so just anti-santa
feminism and comic books and so you know
it's it's it's people really couldn't
get behind her character but no less um
let's see who should be pit Patrol I'm
not I'm not gonna talk about that
best MCU movie so far I am man one just
because it started at all I can watch
Iron Man 1 multiple times and and that's
always my favorite
do I have tickets for age of Ultron
nobody to buy him oh my god I'm so glad
you mentioned that because I guarantee
the midnight show me is gonna be sold
out so I definitely do get online and
buy those tickets I mean we had like a
month they may not even be out yet now
that I think about it but but yeah I
definitely need to get those let's see
I heard the Inhumans movie make it
canned to make room for spider-man and
allow it as a shield to focus on their
introduction of the MCU I don't know
anything about that it'd be
disappointing if it was I would love to
see the Inhumans movie come out I'd be
disappointed if they cancelled it but
you know I don't I don't want to see
that I definitely want to see I
definitely want to see like an Inhumans
film I want to see Vin Diesel play Black
Bolt and whoever else play Medusa and so
on and so forth but I really want to see
any of humans film because it'd be a
great way to introduce one of the
richest continuities of Marvel Comics
into the MCU the Inhumans are wildly
underrated in Marvel Comics and the
problem the reason why the Inhumans
never really shine the way they could
have was because they were considered to
be like a poor man's x-men like a poor
man's mutant group kind of like a
knockoff but with the mutants more or
less being eliminated entirely kind of
being cast down I think it'd be a great
idea to keep the Inhumans around oh oh
my god I love the movie marathon insane
god I wish they had that around here
somewhere and that'd be awesome to go
see I got tickets I live in the UK is
the DC Cinematic Universe part of the DC
Comics universe I think so but I'm not a
hard person sure if it is though it'll
be confirmed in convergence that'll tell
us that that's actually the case but
anyway guys so we're at the 45 minute
mark like I said this was gonna be kind
of short I am who I'm running on fumes
I am definitely tired but the good thing
is I've done all kinds of research for
the for the Deadpool Deadpool thing so
here's my question for you guys
here's the one to ask you guys before I
took off when it comes to DC in
conversions there's gonna be a lot going
on or I guess a Marvel marvel
I guess secret Wars and conversions we
know that secret Wars is gonna last like
six months I think and convergence is
gonna last a couple months initially
what I'll probably end up doing at what
I'm considering doing is doing two
videos a day one for DC and one for
Marvel and let me know if that's
something you guys would be interested
in because I'm kind of curious I'll give
you guys some time here to answer but
I'm curious how do you guys feel about
that would you guys be interested in
seeing two videos a day or would that be
too much I can't say they're gonna be 20
minute videos just because they're going
to be the stories are gonna be so short
but nonetheless you know I think it
would be I think it'd be cool I think
it'd be pretty interesting to see two
videos a day I don't know how long it'll
last
because that's a really easy way to get
burned out but I still think it'd be
kind of cool so so let me know let me
know what you guys think about that
about doing doing two videos a day but
anyway um Forge explained but yes so
with that being said um I'm gonna go
ahead and bring this episode to an end I
know again it was a short one and a lot
of you guys are getting here I'm sorry
but you know I'm running on like two
hours of sleep and I am totally
exhausted so yeah I will catch you guys
later peace